Narrator: BAKLAVA, A SWEET TREAT
FROM THE MIDDLE EAST
MADE FROM PASTRY,
SYRUP, AND NUTS.
FIVE CENTURIES AGO, AS TODAY,
THE FIRST JOB OF THE DAY
IS TO PRODUCE THE DOUGH.
WHEAT FLOUR, WATER,
EGG, SALT,
AND A GLUG OF OLIVE OIL
ARE CHURNED TOGETHER
IN PRECISE AMOUNTS.
ONCE IT'S MIXED,
THE FINISHED DOUGH
IS CARVED UP
AND ROLLED INTO BALLS.
BUT THE BAKLAVA DOUGH
SHOULD BE SO FINE,
IT'S TRANSPARENT.
AND THESE LUMPS
CLEARLY AREN'T.
SO FIRST, THEY'RE FED
INTO A ROLLING MACHINE
TO BE FLATTENED AND STRETCHED
TILL THEY'RE 33 FEET LONG.
THE FLATTENED DOUGH IS THIN
BUT NOT THIN ENOUGH.
SO COMPANY OWNER
NADIR GULLU
AND HIS TEAM GO TO WORK
WITH ROLLING PINS
OF HARD PEAR
OR HORNBEAM WOOD
AND PLENTY OF ELBOW GREASE.
IT'S NOT ALL ABOUT
MUSCLE POWER.
THE UNPOLISHED MARBLE TABLES
ALSO GRIP THE DOUGH.
SHEETS OF DOUGH ARE LAYERED
ON TOP OF EACH OTHER,
10 TO A PIN.
TO STOP THEM FROM STICKING,
THE FACTORY
GOES THROUGH OVER 550 POUNDS
OF STARCH A DAY.
THE STARCH ALLOWS THEM
TO PEEL THE LAYERS APART
TO REWORK THE DOUGH.
TURNING LEAVES OF PHYLLO
INTO BEAUTIFUL BAKLAVA
IS A MANY-LAYERED,
MULTI-CHEF RELAY RACE.
NADIR'S SON, MURAT,
STARTS THE PROCESS
WITH LAYERS OF GOSSAMER PASTRY.
MEANWHILE, THE RESIDENT
NUTCRACKER GRINDS PISTACHIOS.
A SHARP BLADE CHOPS,
RATHER THAN CRUSHES, THE NUTS,
PRESERVING
THEIR NATURAL OILS,
SO THEY REMAIN
FULL OF FLAVOR.
MURAT GOES NUTS
WITH A LAYER OF PISTACHIOS.
THEN THESE ARE COVERED
BY ANOTHER 20 SHEETS OF PASTRY.
TO MAKE ONE TRAY
OF BAKLAVA,
IT TAKES AT LEAST 3 HOURS.
AND YOU NEED
AT LEAST 10 PEOPLE.
Narrator:
A SOAKING OF MELTED BUTTER
AND THEN IT'S INTO
A 329-DEGREE-FAHRENHEIT OVEN
FOR 45 MINUTES,
GIVE OR TAKE
A CRUCIAL 60 SECONDS.
44, 45
OR MAYBE 46 MINUTES LATER,
THE BATCH IS DRENCHED
IN BOILING SUGAR SYRUP.
AND IT'S READY TO EAT.